so right here Ben's got the gun on Ben
fury does his quick little move and then
he takes he ejects the clip clip falling
to the ground and that's why later it is
a little weird that he tries to shoot
the gun after discharging the clip you
forgot it's in the heat of the moment
just happened but it also tells the
audience that gun has no bullets so now
I'm gonna throw it at you hi I'm Anna
Bowden and I'm a school I'm Ryan Fleck
Ryan I'm Ryan flack anyway we're the
writers and directors of Captain Marvel
and this is our scene there's a little
scene with Sam Jackson a young Nick Fury
he's trying to escape
scroll agents he doesn't know who's a
skull and who isn't his girl and he's
trying to escape from them in this big
archive and then this happens
[Music]
was it something I said
oh now come on so a lot of this is Sam
actually fighting with ben mendelsohn in
this scene which is great because you
know Sam is actually almost 70 years old
at the time we shot this and he's in
fantastic shape and he did a lot of his
own stunts which was really impressive
did Sam pay you to say that he did some
of it is his stunt double
Sam's double is played by Keanu gee he's
been with Sam for a really long time he
does a lot of his guns he sounds
incredible he's wonderful
Keller is Sam ba but this is the moment
when he realizes for sure there's
something strange going on here because
Keller is super strong all of a sudden
so this is fun we had Sam's devil and
some wires there getting pulled into the
wall and here again oh and if you're
thinking that 31 means anything behind
Sam's head it doesn't it was just there
on the floor or does it so what we love
about Ben in this movie is that he's
such a fun villain he has a little bit
of attitude and a little bit of humor
now you know I don't really need these
to see but they do kind of complete the
look and we really let him kind of go
for it and and just bring all of his
personality to the role don't you think
there she is Carol Danvers at the Nine
Inch Nails shirt which is super awesome
we had to get permission from Trent
Reznor to use this shirt I don't think
there was a monetary negotiation or than
um one no there wasn't one that I was
aware of he just wanted to see the shirt
like literally not a picture of the
shirt he wanted somebody to bring him
the shirt a PA took it over to his
office and he looked at the shirt said
cool you can use a shirt which is so
cool cuz we were big nine snails fans
when we were teenagers in the 90s we
definitely wanted to differentiate the
sound of Iron Man the sound of Carol
Danvers laughter organic they come from
within her and we wanted to have more of
an organic and less of a mechanical
sound it took us a long time developing
the look of those photon blast kind of
organic and wave-like but we wanted it
to still have like the depth and power
of something that's super repulsive
whenever we're shooting Sam and wordy
aging him it's just Sam he's got some
dots on his face but we're using all of
his performance including his body
performance and Lola who's the company
who kind of took the lead on the
de-aging did amazing job hand painting
every frame slimming him a little bit
and he was wearing a wig so that's all
just practical his hair is
and so here we have Clark Gregg as
Colson he thinks that we didn't do it he
has a small part in the movie but it's
so important because one of the really
fun things about this movie is it also
an origin story for Nick Fury and and
Coulson and their friendship that you'll
get to see in the other movies like
Avengers they're not down here let's try
it there she did she's wrong Bri ain't
trained for a long time and became super
strong and that metal and also that
photon blast earlier also actually we
all Bri thanks for watching their
breakdown
you can catch Captain Marvel and in
theaters on March 8 and you can buy your
tickets I'm novice girl he's not his
girl
[Music]